Yeah.
You Josh Gates.
Oh good.
Josh,
ask me an easy question.
Young suggested that the Christian Myth failed to articulate Christ descended
into hell and that this resulted in the mass shadow projection of the West.
Thoughts?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm going to refer to my book again.
I talked about this and rule seven,
pursue what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
In that Chapter I discussed there's this idea in Christianity that Christ took
the sins of the world onto himself and I think that's very much related to the
idea of descent into hell.
They're not exactly the same thing,
but I,
but I'm going to address the first one and it will shed light on the second.
So what does it mean that the Messiah is archetype Lee?
The figure who takes the sins of the world onto himself,
what it means practically speaking or psychologically speaking.
And I've tried this with some of my clients who were very naive.
It means to read the history of the world as if you were the perpetrator of the
evils that you read about instead of the victim or the noble intervener.
You know,
I talked to somebody the other day about the movie Schindler's List and
Schindler was this German industrialist who saved a very large number of Jews
that were in danger of well endanger of,
of,
of the final solution.
And one of the things he said was,
well,
you know,
when people watch Schindler's list,
they always think they'd be Schindler and on if they don't think they'd be
Schindler,
maybe they think they'd be the Jewish victim of the Nazis,
but they almost never think that they'd be the Nazi persecutor.
And that's a big mistake because when you read about history,
then you're reading about you,
even if the you is the perpetrator.
And unless you understand that,
then someone else has to be the perpetrator.
And if someone else is the perpetrator,
well then you have a devil that you can chase and you know,
maybe you've identified the devil properly because you know now and then it's
like John Wayne Gacy or Ted Bundy or someone like that.
And you've actually,
you know,
you've identified the perpetrator.
But so often,
okay,
far too often
the best way to constrain the malevolence outside is to constrain the
malevolence within.
And so if you don't have a locale for the evil of the world and you have to
externalize it because the evil of the world certainly exists now,
it's a better solution to assume that your
fully capable of the terrible things that people have been capable of throat,
the history of humanity,
and to contend with that genuinely.
And there's massive advantages to that.
I mean,
first of all,
it can actually produce and remarkable increment self esteem because you know,
if you're just a rabbit and you freeze whenever a wolf looks at you,
then you're just a frozen rabbit and that's not so good.
You're just a scared rabbit.
But maybe you learn one day that you're not a rabbit that you like,
you're actually quite the damn monster and you've got teeth and you could really
use them in an underhanded and horrible way.
This is why people like anti hero movie so much hay because they go and see the
villains,
the mafia guys and these tough guys and they antiheroes that populate our
imagination and think,
oh yeah,
well I'd really read it like to be someone like that.
And the thing is,
is that being useless and week,
it's better to be a monster then to be useless and weak.
And that's because being useless and weak makes you a worst monster then a
monster.
That's why it's not like being a monster is good,
but weak,
useless monster is the worst kind of monster because that's a sort of monster.
A little jump in the dark and sink its teeth into the back of your neck instead
of confronting you forthrightly in the alley.
And so if you start to see yourself as the perpetrator of historical
malevolence,
you know,
if you can imagine yourself as an Auschwitz camp guard,
if you see yourself as,
as the,
the,
the vicious villain of the human story,
then all of a sudden you've got a lot more respect for yourself and you can
unlock that internal monster and not internal monster.
And then maybe you can tame the damn thing or at least bring it in,
bring it into some sort of partnership with yourself.
And then when someone pushes you around,
you can let a little bit of that out in your eyes just a little bit and you can
say it would be better for you.
And for me if you didn't continue to do that and you can actually mean it.
And then actually it will stop because if you let a little bit of that out when
you tell someone to stop,
the probability that they'll stop is extremely high.
And then just a tiny like vision of the monster you could become is enough to
keep order in your house.
Hey,
and maybe in your state.
And so the mass shadow projection of the West,
well,
you know,
here's another thing.
So one of the things the Christians figured out was that,
um,
the snake in the garden of Eden was also Satan.
I can't get into that.
It's too complicated.
You'll have to read chapter seven if you want a full explication of that idea.
I,
that's as good an answer as to the question as I can manage.
Tonight,
I spent all day,
let's see,
all day.
I got up at seven and I worked all day till five on this video I told you about.
So I made about 400 anets or something like that.
So I'm a little bit on the burnt outside tonight,
so.